5 en 53 votos a favor y 47 en contra que
también brawn jackson fue confirmada
como la próxima jueces de la corte
suprema de eeuu tres republicanos
votaron a favor de ella susan collins de
el estado de maine lisa murkowski de
alaska y mitt romney de yuta mitt romney
recordemos fue ex y ex candidato
presidencial que tarde brawn jackson
usted lo decía vio esta votación desde
la casa blanca compañía de joe biden y
además pues pasa que tan james brown
jackson hacer entonces la juez de la
corte suprema más joven esto después de
que éste vendrá jr quien reemplazará si
ahí se había comprometido ya en días
anteriores a renunciar a su cargo para
precisamente darle el puesto a una a una
juez mucho más joven de corte liberal
sin embargo seven wire seguirá siendo
juez de la corte suprema hasta que
termine el periodo judicial que termina
este verano y a partir de octubre de
este año
qué tal si brawn jackson entonces pasa a
hacer ya juez de la corte suprema
escuchar a sus primeros argumentos en
octubre esto sin embargo no cambia está
esta tendencia que hay en la corte
suprema de justicia de eeuu donde seis
de los magistrados son de corte
conservador y tres son de corte y el
liberal es decir los liberales tienen
minoría es de resaltar también que este
período de confirmación a pesar de la
oposición de los republicanos duró sólo
42 días que es mucho menos de lo que en
promedio han durado otros periodos de
confirmación a la corte suprema de
justicia